foreign
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen here we go we're
playing White against a 2286 all right
this is the highest rated person we
faced thus far and I'm gonna switch back
to one E4 we've done D4 a couple of
games in a row let's go back to E4 and
see how our opening is hold up at a very
high level well we are going to stick to
our guns I'm gonna play the Smith Mora
which is kind of a scary Prospect
because I don't know the smithmore well
enough I think to justify playing it at
this level
but if we lose you know if flag
demonstrates a superior knowledge the
opening then so be it okay I'm actually
happy to see Knight F6 because
this transposes the game into a an
elephant Sicilian as
you guys know the move here is E5 and
most Smith motor players are
disappointed when they see the declined
Mora when they see the move Knight F6
but in reality the elephant is in and of
itself a very entertaining opening and
I've played it religiously in previous
speed runs and I feel like I know it a
lot better than I know the more so in
this position there is basically
three moves
um Queen takes D4 is a sideline that
contains a lot of Venom I know Mark
recommends it I don't know it well at
all Queen takes D4 is very interesting
line to explore
now most people play C takes D4 but the
the modern treatment of the position
is actually to start with the flexible
Knight F3 exploiting the fact that D
takes C3 is impossible because the pawn
is pinned to the Knight so Knight F3 is
is what almost everybody nowadays plays
as a matter of course D6 yeah so this is
one of several possible lines
and now and now we play C takes D4 we
recapture the pawn and the main line is
Knight C6 in this position now we're
just following
Mainline Theory and does anybody know
what the main move here is for white
it's very important to be precise
because otherwise white runs the risk
of essentially overextending the center
and getting some sort of crappy iqp
position
so a lot of people here they default to
the move e takes D6 but that is exactly
the kind of crappy iqp position you want
to avoid
uh Knight C3 is not great
because black takes on C3
and then I think plays D takes E5 we'll
check that after the game Knight C3
actually might be kind of interesting
but the main move is Bishop C4
developing with Tempo and immediately
harassing the Knight on D5 now we drive
the bishop to B5
now D takes E5 Knight takes E5 Bishop D7
his main line
white gets the two Bishops Knight takes
D7 Queen takes D7
white gets the two Bishops in an active
position but in return we are saddled
with an iqp and that iqp does become a
potential liability in certain positions
so we need to continue following the
main line here the move is Knight C3
uh threatening D5 and essentially this
force is black sand which is E6 now we
Castle
and the traditional main line is Bishop
E7 that is what people used to play
automatically people still play it it's
still it's still very much a reputable
move but I think white is slightly
better according to Modern Theory
recently top GMS have been playing a
couple of different moves in this
position I don't know
exactly what is the most popular right
now I know that A6
has been tested uh at the top level I
know also Rook d8 is a movie yeah Rook
date is on the board
and here kind of we're on a run at this
point I'm I'm no longer
overly familiar with the theory so let's
try to figure it out
uh over the board
yeah so Rook d8 is uh is totally logical
it it attacks the D4 Pawn now black is
threatening to capture D4 with the queen
now what you should what you should
understand about these lines is that
sometimes you sacrifice the pawn on D4
for an initiative so the prospect of
black taking on D4 before castling isn't
the scariest
Prospect like imagine if black plays
Queen takes D4 here imagine that it's
black to move well we can meet Queen
takes D4 with Queen F3 and Black's Queen
on D4 is kind of a Sitting Duck in the
center so it's not the end of the world
that the pawn is attacked but that
doesn't mean we should just give it away
for free
we should at least
see if we can develop a tempo so some of
you might be tempted by the move Bishop
G5 but that's a little bit myopic
because then black responds with Bishop
E7 and remember that in an iqp structure
trades generally favor the side that
faces the isolated Queen Pawn so instead
I think we should go Bishop E3 as
passive as this move looks it's still a
developing move and it fulfills the job
of defending the D4 pawn bishop B7
okay now
we can rewind a move
and I will remind you that Bishop E7
here which is the traditional main line
is generally met with Queen G4 that is
the theoretical continuation so we
should test the move Queen G4 here
or queen G4 here Blackwell castle and
then in comparison to
the other position it seems like black
has made an improvement like the
insertion of Rook d8 Bishop E3 is
probably in Black's favor because Bishop
H6 is no longer possible in that
situation due to Queen takes D4
let's see if we can try to improve on
Queen G4 let's see if we can try to find
a trickier continuation I'm actually
going to think about this for a couple
of moments I'm going to think about this
for about a minute in silence
and then I'll share my thoughts with you
and I encourage you to do the same by
the way
let's play Rook C1 let's play Rook C1
which is a move that some of you
suggested
already previously
the idea of this move is to put pressure
on the Knight on C6 and I'm basically
trying to stay flexible here
yeah Queen G4 I didn't really see a
clear follow-up after Castle so the
black Castle is here we might still play
Queen G4 in order to vacate the D1
Square for the other Rook like ideally
we don't want the queen to be on D1 we
want the F Rook to be on D1 because it's
a more effective defender of the pawn
okay black does Castle
but obviously Queen G4 is not forced
like we have
many possible continuation also
interesting is Queen H5
trying to develop the queen onto a
somewhat more aggressive Square
definitely worthy of consideration
although Queen H5 black can play A6
and after the trade I don't really see a
clear continuation yeah Queen F3 is also
interesting to pressure the Knight on C6
into kind of semi-threatened Bishop
takes C6 which would [ __ ] blex
queenside Pawn structure that actually
might be
ooh but it comes to a tactic Queen F3
there's Knight takes D4
and I think the complications work out
for black
I think I see another way no but that
doesn't work either let's think 94 walks
into F5 which I think could be pretty
nasty
Knight A4 black plays Knight D5 and
establishes a knight in the center
yeah I think we should just resign
hmm
yeah this is such a tricky line it's a
rook d8 move I I'll have to update my
my theoretical knowledge which is
already scant to begin with
but this just seems like we have
absolutely nothing
okay we need to somehow find a way to
no I think the position is equal we need
to find a way at least to create some
trouble for black
94 this F5 move is so annoying Knight C5
Bishop C5 DC 95 just looks like white is
worse there
Queen G4 again he got he has F5 ah but
maybe there we can drop the queen back
to F3 then black plays F4 uh then black
plays F4
so Queen G4 F5 Queen G3
but if and if A6 maybe we can take and
then perhaps we can exploit the weakness
of the of the plot but after Queen G4
the problem is also that black and just
play A6 and if we play Bishop H6 ah then
Bishop F6 maybe we can play Bishop takes
C6 okay let's give it a shot let's give
Queen G4 a shot and probably that
basically means that Rook C1 was a
mistake I think what I should have done
is just gone Queen G4 castles and then
Rook 8 D1 because now we have to worry
about the weakness of the spawn whereas
if the Rook is on D1 you know that would
be a much safer option Rook C1 was
was was short-sighted
gosh people are uh people are beasts in
the opening everybody knows they're
chessable
except yours truly
yeah well the problem with A6 Bishop D3
is twofold the first is that we
relinquish control over the D4 Pawn the
second is that this idea of black going
F5 is super super nasty because although
the move F5 weakens the E6 spawn and
that's the main drawback of that move
it potentially just prize our fingers
from the ledge because if black can play
F5 and then F4 dislodging
the bishop for me three if the bishop
has to drop back to D2 then again all of
this comes down to the weakness of the
D4 Pawn we must keep this Pawn protected
at all costs the good news though is
that we finally gotten our opponent to
think that tells me that we're finally
on a Level Playing Field
and this is where hopefully we can
figure out a way to cause trouble here
one move I'm hoping black might play and
fall into a trap is the move A6 here
but I don't think he's gonna do that
why is A6 a truck so if he or she plays
A6
then Bishop takes C6 Queen takes C6
and it may appear that we have no
obvious discoveries along the C file but
we can throw in Bishop H6
forcing black to play Bishop F6 and then
we play the move Knight C3 to E4
attacking the queen and threatening to
capture the bishop on F6 because
remember the G Pawn is pinned to the
king
yeah of course after A6 Bishop takes C6
black should play Pawn takes but that is
the ideal scenario if we can force
Bishop takes C6 BC then at least we have
created a corresponding weakness
in Black's position right then we'll
have mutual weaknesses we'll have the
iqp black will have a weak Pawn on C6
right okay so our opponent is still deep
in the tank which is good
maybe Queen G4 is not as uh shabby as it
may appear
it's actually not so simple for black
also to choose a move here it's like a
very very okay King h8 so our opponent
chooses a very like slow positional
option that gives us the time we need
to bring the Rook to D1 and protect the
pawn on D4 which makes me a lot less
worried about the prospect of F5 it's
still an annoying move
but after F5
we can drop our Queen back to G3
and F4 of course is not really possible
because if Bishop takes F4
okay
so I think we've stabilized the position
it's probably still equal like probably
all zero zero zero but lots of
possibilities here to outplay somebody
okay so what other observations are we
making here well
we've got our pieces on nice squares
we've got to work on nice I guess I'm
kind of reserving
my my thinking until black smoke because
Black's move
will completely change how we approach
this position like the move F5 here is
completely different from the move A6
from a general perspective it would be
nice if at some point we could make some
lifts with H3 or even with G3 it would
also be nice I mean probably the ideal
Square for the queen at this point is F3
the queen has done its job on G4 once
the black king has moved away from G8
the queen on G4 is sort of a Sitting
Duck it's not really doing anything so
on F3 it would at least be putting
pressure on the Knight on C6
quote-unquote threatening Bishop takes
C6 well are we looking to double Rooks
here eh I don't think so I think the D5
square is so well protected by black
that hoping to push the Deep on okay
maybe we will I wouldn't rule it out
completely but doubling Rook seems
really cumbersome here I feel like it
would give black a lot of time it would
in basketball there's the term
telegraphing a pass right when you hold
the basketball over your head and you
aim at the player you're trying to pass
it to that often leads to a turnover
in chess it's kind of similar in a
complicated middle game if a plan takes
too long you want to make sure that you
don't get into a situation where your
opponent allows all of the moves you
want to make and then you waste a bunch
of Tempe and then your opponent makes
one move and it stops your main concept
if that makes sense are you more
inclined to this well G3 versus H3 is
kind of arbitrary
the reason I kind of like G3 is that it
blunts F5 F4 simultaneously while
creating Luft
of course H3 is the traditional
traditional way of creating Luft
but you shouldn't be afraid to play the
move G3 if your opponent lacks a light
scored Bishop so I would make this move
without a second thought of course it's
a little bit weakening if black had a
light squared Bishop lurking somewhere
G3 would be a lot more committal
no we don't even need to refi and Kettle
the bishop we could just play G3
and Black's not going to exploit these
squares easily
oh my cat is Jeff hopefully you're at
least able to follow my general
statements you know
I'm trying to be as simple as possible
in in my
explanation of how I'm thinking about
this position 95 centralizing the Knight
I think we should take that night I
wouldn't want to allow black to
establish
an incredibly strong piece on D5 and I
would much rather deal with a queen on
D5 than a knight on D5 because a queen
on D5 is not stable it can be chased
away
whereas the Knight on D5 causes a lot of
unpleasant
externalities in our position so let's
trade
obviously Ed is terrible because we
would trade queens and take twice on C6
okay so what do we do now we have a
dilemma
I think the sort of vanilla move
is Bishop takes C6 but then the position
becomes very much
sterile I think the position becomes
sterile we each will have a dark squared
bishop and black will have a nicely
positioned Queen on D5 I think we should
try to keep our Bishop pair and we
should try to remove the queen from D5
with Bishop C4 of course that abandons
the possibility of trading on C6 on the
other hand it makes it a more distinct
possibility that we might one day be
able to eradicate our weakness by
pushing D5
so in such complicated middle games
everything is a trade-off right and no
one move is going to contain all
strengths and no weaknesses right
there's going to be downsides and
upsides and your goal is just to like
maximize the upsides and minimize the
downsides the easy easier said than done
obviously
Queen D6 all right
I like actually seeing this one but I
feel like Queen D6 is probably not the
best spot for the queen
and maybe just maybe this gives us the
chance to start
accumulating a little bit of an
initiative here now
the first thing that everybody should
see is of course the possibility of D5
unfortunately I think D5 fails because
of Knight E5
then black takes the bishop on C4 and
follows up with e takes D5 I'll make all
these moves after the game on the board
true potato thank you for the sub so
there's a couple of moves that are
catching my eye here
one of them is hmm
so we should still remember that F5 is a
potentially annoying possibility
one possibility we have is to play Queen
G4 to E4
in order to centralize our Queen
so that after D5 Knight E5 no longer
comes with tempo the other reason I like
winning four is because of course it
potentially sets up a battery with
Bishop D3 so we can also play Queen H5
for the same reasons but the reason I
like Queen E4 a little bit more
is because it discourages although it
doesn't prevent F5 it only discourages
it
let's think about this for a little
while longer
we can also Play Bishop F4 by the way
but after Bishop F4 we abandon
we abandoned this pawn and I'm not sure
I like that we can also make a very calm
move like A3 we can just continue
improving our position there's nothing
wrong with that and at this point we can
also try to double our Rooks with Rook
D2 or even Rook D3
taking that Avenue of thought
I'm starting to come up with an
interesting concept
now this is a risky concept
but I think it might pay off
yeah Rook D3 Knight before we go Bishop
F4 with Tempo and then swing The Rook to
H3
all right ladies and Gentlemen let's
risk it here we go
now I'm positive this is not the oh and
I should have gone Rook C3 notebook Rook
C3 there was 95. wow that's really cool
actually
had we played instead Rook to C3
with the same idea of lifting The Rook
up to H3 black would have had this weird
looking move Knight C6 to E5 forcing a
favorable trade because the Knight would
have been Untouchable because the Rook
on D1 would be a Sitting Duck
well the point is we go Rook H3 and we
go for checkmate
at some point we will end up sacrificing
the pawn on D4
it's only a question of when we
sacrifice it not a question of whether
we sacrifice it
the good thing about sacking the pawn on
D4 is that once it is captured the
Center opens up and if
Black's King is weak then you might get
a situation where black is overextended
Right opening up the center generally
favors the attacking side in okay that's
a lie obviously depends on the position
but in this type of position given the
black lacks a light squared Bishop and
given that Black's Queen is in alignment
with the Rook I feel like
even if black captures D4 in some
situations it could lead to Black being
overextended I think you know what I'm
saying
and also the bishop here right we have
the what I was trying to say is that we
have the bishop bear and that is what
could benefit us
in the event of the center opening up
now I should also keep in mind as black
is thinking that we don't need to rush
with the move Bishop F4 right we can
also play a little bit more slowly we
can double Rooks on the D file
we're under no obligation to follow
through on our plan
in case black does something drastic or
crazy
and I talked about this in the last
Speed Run game right you have to be
flexible once you make a move that has
an idea that doesn't mean you have to
follow up on that idea no matter what
and I think this might be a case in
point Bishop F6 is a great move by our
opponent great move by our opponent I
think the point is to play G6 and to
build a defensive construction to refi
and Kettle the bishop and actually here
I think it's much more prudent
for us to oh wait there's a nasty idea
there
wait a minute let's think
it's much more prudent for us to not go
Bishop F4 I don't think Bishop F4 is a
good idea here
actually maybe it is let's see there
there there
no it isn't it isn't wow there's a
ridiculous tactic here
trying to figure out a way to circumvent
this tactic gosh Bishop F6 is such a
good move
kind of sours the party to be honest
we need four maybe is also interesting
I have to say I'm getting outplayed he's
getting a sound layout played here
yeah I blundered if Rook D1 there's this
weird move Queen before and then if
Bishop B3 he's got Knight E5
and black wins an exchange in the game
Bishop F6 I totally underestimated
let's go Queenie for
no no it's just that there are various
people people at this level are like
ridiculously strong
but okay the game is not over I mean
we just need to find a way to keep our
D4 Pawn protected Bishop B5 but that
just encourages black to take the pawn
on D4 the point of Queen E4
is to aim at the B7 Pawn that's my
thinking my thinking is to discourage
Knight takes D4 because then maybe we'll
take on B7 or by keeping our pieces
clumped together like this we're
ensuring that there's going to be less
tactics having to do with undefended
pieces so for instance after Knight C4
maybe we'll play Rook C to D1
double Rooks try to provoke black into
playing e65 and then grab the pawn on B7
and in that case I think it's anybody's
game
yeah but the problem is that there's
Bishop takes D4
and the inclusion of the dark squared
Bishop trade is definitely in Black's
favor no doubt about it but what I
calculated was Bishop takes D4
Bishop takes D4 Knight takes D4 Rook C
to D1 doubling Rooks and attack in the
night black has to play five and then we
grab the pawn on B7
and I wouldn't say that white is better
there but I think we're probably not
worse
in that resulting position I think white
can more or less hope to keep the
balance there
black is also getting a little bit I
mean we're both getting low on time
but obviously it's going to favor us
if if black gets let's say under three
minutes
yeah I'm definitely unhappy with the
quality of this game so far I I don't
know exactly what I did wrong but
just get the sense that I
I'm not feeling this position as well as
our opponent but that's that's fine the
game again the game continues
so my guess is that our opponent is
trying to decide which piece
to capture on D4 with
so this guy's Blitz rating is 22 21.
so in the event of let's say
uh
both of us being under a minute I'm be
pretty confident of my chances but
obviously that's not how we want to win
most of our speedrun games we want to
win them on the board
but that doesn't mean you know the time
is never a factor in that I'm going to
deny that in the speeder on most
most people watching it are trying to
improve precisely at this time control
maybe 15 minutes maximum
so you should be
keeping an eye on the way that we're
managing our clock
iqp structures when I say iqp by the way
those listening on YouTube isolated
Queen Pawn iqp this is an iqp structure
the reason it has its own name like why
is ikp not a thing of course it can be a
thing you could have an isolated King
Pawn but the iqp structure arises a lot
more commonly out of a lot of different
types of openings Karo Khan nimso Indian
after the game I'll show you a couple of
ways that you could get the same iqp
position out of like three or four
different openings and iqps are very
hard to play for both sides both sides
you know you really have to study these
structures carefully
to learn how to play them with with
either side there's books that are
written exclusively on iqb structures
now Rook D7 is not scary
notice that we're also sort of eyeing
the move d4 D5
yeah the guy's in the tank he's under
two minutes and Bishop takes D4 wow
good stuff by our opponent okay I think
we should
stick to our guns here the thing is if
we start with the Rook Ceda D1
and then black has E5 and unfortunately
the move order is in Black's favor
but one interesting alternative that I'm
coming up with right now is
a somewhat more Brazen option
which is Rook cd1 E5 and then Bishop G5
trying to keep the bishop here preserve
the bishop pair
black moves The Rook
we swing our Rook to H3 threatening
Checkmate black plays H6
and then we try to
keep the attack going
with a move like Queen F5
oh there are some interesting tactics
there
you know what ladies and gentlemen
given the black is low on time I'm very
tempted to do this I know it's on sound
though
I know it's on sound though so
this might not be exactly in the spirit
of the speedrun but we're gonna do it
anyway
we are going to do it anyway
let's do it Rook cd1
Bishop G5
okay buckle your seat belts this is
gonna be a ride I have a bad feeling
about this We're In Too Deep it's funny
one minute and 40 seconds when you have
it seems like nothing but when your
opponent is thinking you feel like it's
an eternity it's like he's got so much
time to figure out the defense here yeah
Rook H3 Bishop F2 King F2
and remember that there will be a maid
threat on H7 okay Rook C8 that love I
like seeing I feel like Rook D7 would
have been a lot better okay so Rook H3
makes a lot of sense
Rook H3 F5 Quinn H4 H6 though we're kind
of at a dead end there hmm
wait let's not rush okay there's a
couple of other moves here that are
interesting there's Queen F5
so Rook H3 H5 F5 if we sack on H7 and
then go Queen H4 check then Black Goes
King G6 there I'm afraid we have nothing
it's incredible how solid Black's
position is it's like
okay well we kind of have to go Rook H3
we kind of have to
I really don't see an alternative
we have to move first and then think
later
okay if Black Goes F5 here
I think we're gonna drop our Queen back
to E2 and just try to play positionally
because remember we have only sacrificed
upon
I think a lot of people in these
situations they start to panic
completely because they're like oh if
the attack doesn't work out we lose
no we don't lose we're only down upon we
still have the bishop pair we still have
active pieces
so sometimes knowing when to retreat and
just keep the tension that can be a lot
more unpleasant for a person who is in
time pressure you should know this
then tactical moves that lead to forcing
positions
okay
oh my gosh wait
oh
wait wait wait wait wait wait there's an
idea does this work oh my God if this
works
oh my God it does this actually work
wait up wait a minute if this works this
is gonna be like the greatest
combination of the speedrun but I'm
pretty sure it doesn't it can't work
and yet I can't refute it
are you kidding me
okay we're trying it maybe this loses
so Queen G6
Rook H7 check
ing The Rook in the end game now if this
loses
don't be too angry at me and Rook D3
trying to lift The Rook to H3 with mate
I don't see a defense against this
now there is Bishop takes F2 check
obviously I saw that we step aside to H1
and here's the crazy thing now listen
very carefully here's the crazy thing
after Bishop takes F2 check King H1
there is the move Bishop H4 which looks
like it wins the game for black because
well Rook H3 is no longer a check and
black back rank mates as an F1 and yet
he doesn't after Bishop H4 Rook H3 the
Bishop from C4 guards F1
and the bishop simultaneously defends G8
I think the best that black can do is
basically to lose a piece I think we're
winning
oh my God this is beautiful this is very
uncommon to have a combination like this
in the end game it's crazy how this
works out
he's down to 20 seconds I don't think he
sees the defense either there is Rook F4
here
but after Rook F4 we still go Rook H3
nothing helps
all right there we go Rook H3 Rook F4
and Bishop takes F4 Bishop takes G5 and
we win a piece
it worked
okay now all we need or did it work wait
not yet I guess we can't celebrate just
yet
oh my God is he actually defending wait
wait wait
oh my God a bishop F7 almost works
wait wait there must be a wind here
let's just calm down and find it okay I
found it I found it
all we need to do so here's the thing if
we play Rook takes H4 check that would
be terrible because Black Goes King G6
and you guys should see that both
Bishops are hanging
so what we need to do is somehow defend
one of the Bishops first with an
intermediate Movement we have a simple
intermediate move Bishop D3 check and
that's it then we lay Rook takes H4 and
the other Bishop defends the C1 Square
at the bishop on D3 defended F1 the
bishop on G5 defends C1
and black loses a piece unbelievable
okay I am super pumped that we just had
this
this is um I'm gonna click bait the heck
out of this on YouTube
that's it King G8
Rook takes H4 no back rank mate we're up
a piece
and all we need to do is just be careful
and not blunder anything here 96 attacks
the bishop
the biggest shame would be to screw this
up now okay so in such situations again
as I've indicated previously the
simplest is just to go for immediate and
maximal piece simplification
so if you really want to do this
properly
then perhaps the best move is Bishop F5
or Bishop C4 either way
trading the bishop for the Knight but we
could also choose to keep the bishop
here alive which is probably more
objectively accurate and that would mean
playing Bishop E3
but I think that given that we don't
want to screw this up given that we want
to choose the simplest option
I think Bishop F5 is
the safest
just making sure that the bishop still
controls the back rank Square it's
always dangerous to play without Luft
like this
just double always double check that the
back rank square is per se still
protected
that's it we won
and we're over 2200. all right we'll
check with the engine of course but I'm
pretty sure that the that the
combination of sound
okay we've got a lot to analyze
first thing I'm going to do is pull out
my C3 Sicilian book
it's called squeezing the Sicilian
that's right Seth by Alexander califman
so d4cd and the C3 I think this guy was
the first person to decline the Mora in
all of the speedrun
just kind of weird so E5 Knight D5
Knight F3 D6
C takes D4
um we're gonna skip right to the Crux of
the matter now if you're on YouTube or
you're new to this line and you're
getting overwhelmed you can look all of
this up on your own but we basically
followed the traditional main line all
the way up until Rook d8 so I've had a
couple of games in the database in this
position
and just to um
make sure that we're on the same page as
I indicated during the game Bishop E7 is
what people used to play exclusively and
the line goes as follows we go Queen G4
black castles now you might say wait a
second Bishop H6 wins The Exchange in
fact Bishop H6 is a blunder
can anybody tell me why why is Bishop H6
a blunder
and even some GMS have accidentally made
this move
well it's a blunder it's a small blunder
it doesn't lose the game on the spot or
anything but it
loses the pawn yeah Queen takes D4
Queen takes D4 the queen defense G7 the
Knight defends the queen and the queen
attacks the other Queen so white has no
time to take on C6 here
so for that reason
the main move is to start with Bishop
takes C6
now Queen takes C6 is widely considered
to be a mistake because after Bishop H6
Bishop F6 Rook fd1 there is a very very
nasty idea where white goes Knight C3 to
E4 on the next move putting pressure on
the bishop like even if black steps
aside with the King we can still play
Knight E4
and this is a very nasty situation for
black because
well I'm gonna play Knight takes F6 on
the next move and there's nothing you
can do about it
um if Rook G8 I think three games in the
database went Bishop G5
and black is you can major trouble here
all of a sudden takes takes and queen H5
and
you're starting to lose all of your
Pawns
so
it's important for black to play the
move PC
because in comparison after Bishop F6
again you don't have time to play Knight
E4 because black can grab the pawn on D4
I don't remember with which piece but I
think actually maybe with the queen
and black is fine here so white has to
waste the tempo on the Move Rick fd1
giving black the opportunity to shift
the king over to h8 after Knight E4 you
have the time to slide your queen to E7
this is actually the move that we were
lacking with the queen sitting on C6
this queen D7 E7 defensive move is very
very important
ton of games in the database here
uh but I'm pretty sure that after Bishop
G5 white has a small pull this is a a
more pleasant position for white I and I
I've always enjoyed playing this okay
so this is the old main line but like I
said recently in this position
um people have been playing
sorry in yeah in this position people
have been playing
two other different moves one of which
is A6 the other one is the one the black
made in the game which is Rook d8 let's
start by checking the book after Rook d8
the caliphman book recommends the
following line
okay the recommendation is indeed Bishop
E3
so that is indeed the recommendation
Bishop E7
there's a couple of Alternatives if
black plays A6
then after Bishop C6 Queen C6 Rook C1
creating the pin Knight D5
and queen comes out to G4 to delay the
development of the bishop
H5 Queen G5 with a small Initiative for
white according to the authors
so Bishop E7 is indeed the main move in
the book as well
and now okay so Queen G4 is their
recommendation
Calif Ben's recommendation is indeed
Queen G4
so Rook C1 is where we deviate they
don't mention Rooks D1 and I think this
move is completely Toothless the only
other move they mention is Queen to B3
after Queen B3 Black's task could be
simpler castles
Rook fd1
and now the simplest is just Knight D5
leading to a bunch of exchanges
takes takes takes takes takes takes Rook
ac1 Rook A5
A3 Rook C8 equals in the game
butesku against Vol correspondence 2016.
as you guys know
there's a bunch of Correspondence games
in the line that basically means that
it's the best line
so what our opponent played is probably
what black is should play
so after Queen G4
sorry after Queen G4 in this position
black castles and white goes Rook a to
D1 this is the line in the book
Bishop sorry G6 is the main line
if black plays F5 then the queen drops
back to F3 and if Bishop F6 white can
break through with D5 Knight D5 Knight
D5 e takes D5
and who can spot the cute little move
here for white yeah at my level like at
this level
you know if you're 2200 and and you
played a game like this this is what
you're supposed to do you open up you
crack open your book and then you figure
out where you went wrong
no Queen takes you you play Queen takes
no Bishop C4
I think black and play
let's see it's not Bishop C4
okay I think black can play 97 here
it's Bishop takes A7 yeah it's Bishop
takes A7 the the benefit of this move
isn't just that it wins the pawn back
it's also that the bishop can drop back
to B6 attack The Rook
why is attacking The Rook important
because if the Rook moves then black
loses D5
so Bishop A7 is what they give
uh with a small Advantage for white
so for that reason instead of Bishop F6
instead of Bishop take Bishop F6 the
best move is Knight D5 and this actually
equalizes yeah so according to the
authors black actually equalizes with
this line
takes takes takes takes
with another one of these typical
toothless positions equal yeah
black can equalize with castles and with
a move F5 in this position but that
requires very Advanced theoretical
nausea black would have to know
all of this topical stuff
and if black plays G6 then we respond
with D5
Knight takes D5 and again this bishop
takes A7 idea this by the way is how
opening knowledge is acquired at a high
level not only are we looking at the
theory and I know you're probably bored
to death but we're also loading
ourselves up with a typical ideas see
now you're not going to forget about
this idea of going D5 and taking on A7
so it's a double kind of type of
learning yeah you're a learning theory
but you're also learning typical ideas
that occur several times in the line
anyways Queen G4 is probably why it's
best attempt I think after Rook C1
castles white is the one
struggling to equalize
so we played Queen G4 black responds
with King h8 which I thought was a
really good move because it takes this
thing out of Bishop H6
um the Trap by the way that I was hoping
black might fall into
is A6
and here to illustrate what I showed
what I talked about during the game
Bishop C6 and if Queen takes C6
obviously like this never works because
the queen can take the Knight
so you play Bishop H6 forcing the black
Bishop to F6 and now if you've been
paying attention you should know what
the move is
now the move is 94. attacking the queen
and if the queen moves you take the
bishop with mate
so black boost is the game Balor says
yep no idea what's going on in which
position are you confused
I would ignore if you're like not a C3
Sicilian player you could like 2x speed
the last like two or three minutes
but now we get to the fun part which is
actually the game continuation
so King h8 I think is a very vigilant
move as I was discussing during the game
I was also concerned about the prospect
of playing F5
and um here we would have had to decide
where we want to put our Queen
probably we would have put our Queen on
G3
yeah G3 or F3 but the problem with Queen
F3 is I was worried about this move F4
I was worried about the prospect of f4
and here white is experiencing problems
because if Bishop takes F4
there might be a way to win the bishop
actually G5 just wins the bishop G5 just
wins the bishop
um and if white doesn't play Bishop
takes F4 if y drops the bishop back to
D2 the Knight takes D4 is incredibly
strong but this blunders the queen no it
does not because White's Queen is also
hanging with check
recaptures the bishop and black is up
upon does that make sense
so therefore we have to play Queen G3
the main difference is that after F4
Bishop takes F4 the queen is no longer
pinned and here white is surviving white
is actually better
but the drawback of Queen G3 is that it
walks potentially into the move Bishop
D6 attacking the queen and reinforcing
the threat of f4
but the downside of Bishop D6 is that it
cuts off Black's heavy pieces from
aiming at the D4 Pawn so after something
like Queen H3 black can still play F4
but in this case we can drop our Bishop
back to D2 and the pawn on D4 is still
alive because the queen is blocked does
that make sense
visor gaming123 asks us to clarify Queen
F3 F4 Bishop F4 G5 Queen G4 I see what
you're trying to do here but remember
after Rook takes F4 you have only one
Queen you can't be pinning the rook and
taking the Rook at the same time
so the pawn defends the rook and if you
take it then black spawn has been
unpinned
okay hopefully that makes sense after F5
I was planning Queen G3 and I think
white is okay
instead King h8 allows us to bring the
Rook into the game
and our opponent centralizes the Knight
with Knight T5 as you know the main rule
of playing against the isolated Queen
Pawn
is that you want to control the square
in front of the pawn with your pieces if
you don't control the square in front of
your Pawn you run the risk of allowing a
pawn breakthrough we've already seen the
negative the harmful effects the
blackened experience if the pawn reaches
D5
okay 95 Knight takes D5
Queen takes D5 obviously e takes D5
would be a lot worse because we trade
queens and we simply win the pawn on C6
so
Queen takes D5 is derigur and here we
had sort of a major fork in the road
if we wanted to make a draw here we
would take on C6 and then we play a move
like B3 position is completely equal but
I would probably take black here
actually because Black's pieces seem to
be a little bit more zesty
then whites and once again F5 is a
potentially annoying move that we have
to deal with
so a couple of questions Afflicted
7-Eleven asks why not Bishop G5 where
can you clarify where
I'm not sure where Bishop G5 is
appealing to you I mean here if you play
Bishop G5 there's nothing inherently
wrong with this move
it's just that
I mean it leads to a bunch of Trades and
I feel like it's also kind of Toothless
like Bishop takes G5 Queen takes G5
black and play Queen E7
offering the queen trade
and remember black is still controlling
the square in front of the iqp so if you
just start barreling head first toward
an end game you're just gonna end up
being worse
you're just gonna end up being worse
um I've shown you before the karpov
coursnoy game and the iqp one of the
most famous examples of
playing against the iqp and the
how harmful it can be for the side with
the iqp to trade all the pieces sorry
we were here
um is Bishop E3 a problem piece now
Bishop B3 is a defensive piece remember
defensive pieces have a reason to exist
it's not the sexiest piece of life but
it is what's holding together the D4
Pawn I like the placement of this bishop
I think this bishop is sort of the
backbone of our position
okay takes
Queen takes and we decided on the more
Dynamic move Bishop C4 Queen D6
and here of course I I can guarantee you
that I made several moves that the
engine will be laughing at
um it's entirely possible that we should
have gone
for a something safer such as just
doubling the Rooks on the D file to make
sure that the D4 Pawn is perfectly well
protected I think the position here is
about equal right it's balanced we've
got the IQ people we have the bishop
pair and our pieces are relatively
active
um but instead we decided on this
you know very brave approach Rook D3 and
to be honest I just underestimated
Bishop F6
for some reason I was like only
seriously considering
the move night before this is what I
thought black would play and I was
really hoping that we would get a chance
to play Bishop F4
and the point of Bishop F4 is to attack
the queen and the point of attacking the
queen is to open the gates for the white
Rook to reach H3
and the point of reaching H3 is to
develop a direct attack on the H7 Pawn
this could lead to Checkmate very very
quickly maybe black is still like
winning after Queen takes D4 I don't
know
but if black plays Rook takes D4
who can tell me
how white
effects Checkmate as quickly as possible
there's basically Checkmate and tumor
not Checkmate in two moose but in two
moves you can get a situation where
black is helpless against mate
yeah Queen H5 simple move H6 and just
crash through with Bishop takes H6 and
if black can defend this then I I take
my head off
okay maybe G6 keeps black alive for the
time being
but even dropping the queen back let's
say to F3 I think is easy
because the Rook is hanging and there's
a discovery and this is just over
um or or actually Queen E5 check might
be
strong as well oh if you want to
simplify Queen E5 check
okay if King G8 then this is mate
and after F6 there's a very pretty
simplifying combination Queen takes D4
Queen takes D4 and Bishop E3 check
now note that if the black pawn were on
F7 in this position black would have
Queen H4
and black would be able to restore the
material equality but here the pawn
blocks the bishop
so always look for these kinds of
simplifying combinations when you are
attacking it's not only about delivering
checkmate
so anyways I was hoping for that but
after Bishop F6 this takes this thing
out of Bishop F4 because here after
Queen before
the problem is that if we just
obstinately go for Rook H3 I just
couldn't see this working
I felt that in this version
this has no chance of success after G6
I feel like G6 here is a critical
defensive move and I didn't see a way
for us to accumulate
further attacking pieces on the king
side we can't go Queen H4
that's the problem and now we can't go
Queen H5 we can't get our Queen on the H
file so H7 Pawn is safe
yeah Bishop G5 Maybe
this is the way to go
but to be honest even if
I have Queen E7 Queen H4 Bishop G5 is
really nice
I guess black has to trade
ooh but now we're getting to H6 holy
smokes I didn't see Bishop G5
that's such a elegant move just trading
off Black's only Defender
hmm so maybe bishop F4 was actually
worth considering here we'll check with
the engine
yeah I didn't see this I calculated up
until this point and I didn't see Bishop
G5 excellent catch
I don't even know if black has a defense
here again Queen E7 white plays Queen H4
with a double attack and this this is
this ends the game
very interesting we will have to check
this with the computer anyways we
decided on a more conservative approach
Queen E4 dozen bees gifting to fight hag
thank you
Bishop takes D4
and this is where we decided to take the
Brazen risk that ultimately wins us the
game and pays off initially my idea was
to take on D4
play Rook cd1
and then take on B7 but with such a
brilliant Knight on D4 there is no way
the black is worse here black can only
be better
that's when I spotted this idea
of playing Bishop G5
and the interesting thing thank you John
42 for another gift it's a how did I
generate this idea of the crazy rucksack
on H7 so the first thing I saw when I
looked at this position is that if black
plays the move F6 the bishop on C4
controls the king's only Escape Square
so this almost works this almost leads
to mate unfortunately the king is able
to escape but you actually don't need to
sack the queen you can just play Rook H3
straight away
now there's a couple of subtleties that
you have to be aware of a lot of people
would not make this move because they're
worried about Bishop takes F2 check but
this is a phantom concern because after
King takes F2 Queen takes D1 is no
longer a check and queen takes H7 is
mate
now there's a crazy line here black and
play FG check
and where should White's King escape to
what's the accurate move here for white
I think it's actually the only move
whoa whoa whoa whoa not King E1 because
he get mated we go King G3 the king
escapes the checks The Black Queen has
nowhere to move such that it defends H7
without giving itself up
Queen G6 Queen takes G6 and upon his
pinned and there are no checks
no not King E2 because then you take the
Rook with check and not King E3 because
of Queen C5 check
so only G3
what a line
so if G6 and queen takes G6 if G6 then
Queen takes you oh wait
no after G6 we have forced mate
beautiful
oh my God after G6 we have Rook takes H7
King H7 Queen H4 and queen H6 Checkmate
a very classic uh pattern by the way
I've seen this before
I've definitely seen this before
by the way what's amazing is that this
move loses because after Bishop F2 check
King F2 FG check the queen hangs black
wins the queen on G6 and contrast to the
other line
absolutely amazing
and by the way after Bishop F2 you can't
not take the bishop because then black
grabs The Rook with check and this is a
mating attack
wow crazy lines and if H6 then of course
Bishop takes H6 with with mate
so that's what I saw and that's what
really attracted me to the move Bishop
G5 the fact that F6 is not possible
so Rook C8 is a slightly weird move I
was expecting Rook D7 ultimately I don't
think no ultimately that is what allows
this combination to work because after
Rook D7 Rook H3
Queen G6 if we try to do the same thing
that we did in the game obviously it
doesn't work because the Rooks are
aligned with each other and Bishop takes
F2 check leads to a rook trade so what
made this combination possible is the
move Rook C8 amazingly I don't think
Rick C8 is a big mistake provided that
black would have followed up correctly
in this position
so Rook C8 Rook H3
and I think the only way
well the question of how do you know
asks truth the bluff how to how do you
know when to start detecting these
tactical ideas well there's a bunch of
articles on this there's a book called
the Tactical detector
there's a book called invisible chest
with there I am
have an article
on chess.com called the Tactical
detector but basically one Surefire
indicator is when the when your
opponent's king is out of squares so
like the moment black plays F6 the black
king has zero Escape squares and that is
like an automatic short sign that you
should start looking for like mating
ideas
and obviously like when you have a bunch
of pieces staring at the opponent's king
there's no secret there's no crazy like
intuitive ability it's more like I've
got pieces that are in the proximity in
the vicinity of my opponent's king
so after Rook H3 I think the key for
black was to play F5
here if we sacrifice on H7
what I calculated at first was Queen H4
King G6
I briefly got excited
about the move Bishop E2
threatening made in one but it's way too
slow and black can defend with Rook h8
it's way too slow in black and Defender
with Rook 8 shade and black consolidates
the extra Rook
so I had black played F5 we would have
gone Queen H4
but here I think black can simply play
H6 and
while this looks impressive in reality
White's pieces are just kind of stranded
on the King on the king's side black
threatens Bishop takes F to check
and things could get really bad here for
white really really quick I just don't
see a way for white to follow up on the
attack
what we would have done in this position
is the incredibly tricky move sorry
Queen E2
who can tell me what Queenie 2 threatens
like what if black plays
just sort of like a nonchalant move
like A6
yeah it creates a hidden threat Rook H7
and queen H5 and suddenly the King has
mated black has to give up the queen
so after we need to my guess is that
black should play a move like Queen G6
but okay the game is not over let me
play Rook G3
and just notice that we have a lot of
attacking potential nonetheless we still
have good practical attacking chances
even though I'm positive that the
objective evaluation is probably
something on the order of minus one or
minus 1.5 not disputing that white is
worse here maybe H6 is the move but it's
not so easy for black to avoid
blundering in a position like this he
gets a rook in a piece though but still
Black's King is really really weak in
that position white is basically winning
hey the king is still going to be hunted
there
so anyways Queen G6 is the Fateful move
and after Queen G6 fg6
anyone listening who has done a fair
amount of puzzle Rush
should be familiar with this kind of
idea of the sack on H7 followed by
a mate on the H file
there there's like a million different
iterations of the same idea where you
basically the king is stuck on the H
file
you sacrifice a piece to open the H file
and then you use a heavy piece the
remaining heavy piece to deliver
check on the H files so for example very
simple example from one of my games
just to show you that like pattern
recognition is actually a thing it's not
a invented concept you know
this is a very simple example from one
of my games
it's a crazy looking position but I was
able in this position to identify the
typical tactical pattern the bishop sits
on E6 it covers the king's only Escape
square and so the simple winning line is
Knight takes C5
my opponent was relying on he takes D3
the queen is hanging and the Knight is
hanging but now Knight takes G6 ends the
game same exact concept you clear the H
file and now Queen H3 results in a very
simple checkmate
okay so you should be familiar with the
underlying concept so if the white Rook
had already been on T3 everybody in this
room
should immediately understand that this
is the mating concept but I have also
seen examples of combinations where you
play a move like Rook D3 it sounds
absurd that black has no way to defend
against made and yet that is exactly the
case but the bottom line
is that it doesn't cost any money to
test these types of lines in your mind
it's just such a nice position
it's such a beautiful position because
like the king is cut off the other
Bishop sits on the G pawns not allowing
black to create love to the move G5 but
what's craziest about this to me isn't
even that there's no stopping Rook H3
it's that after Bishop F2 white is still
winning with King H1 the craziest thing
is what this bishop is capable of it's
defending F1 and G8 and both of those
things are mission critical
so no matter where Black's Bishop goes
you're opening up the defense of the F1
Square reinforcing the threat of Rook H3
black found the most resilient defense
which is Bishop H4 Rook H3 and Rook F4
but now we simply take back and the g
pawns are doing our work for us this is
still me
black is forced to give up all of his
pieces in order to clear the G6 score by
that point it's too late Knight D4 is
another excellent move by our opponent
by the way
setting a trap Rook H4 King G6 and black
is okay
but we first drop our Bishop back
forcing the king back and then we take
on H4
incredible incredible idea
um maybe I'm over hyping it a little bit
but the fact that it happens in an end
game
and the fact that like his Bishop takes
F2 check and it still doesn't help and
our King is basically mated it's just
totally nuts chess is just such a crazy
game
like we could be getting out played the
entire time and then all of a sudden
there's this mating combination of
nowhere
and oh and the fact that the bishop on
G5 defends C1 the bishop on C4 defends
F1 and black Strokes are aligned on the
F and C files perfectly just where we
need them to be
yeah the fact that the other Bishop
controls C1 is so crazy
nuts absolutely nuts but I hope you
enjoyed the game folks
um maybe the analysis at the beginning
was a little bit too technical if so I
apologize
but I really wanted to be thorough I
wanted to make sure that we had properly
considered the opening
we can check really quickly before I
finish the video
uh the engine
assessment and a couple of key positions
let's um
check the engine analysis in a couple of
key positions before we uh pause for
today
so
okay actually Queen G4 is best so this
the computer actually likes this
wow we actually were playing really
really well
yeah Queen E4 immediately and white is
apparently better
Queen E4 the engine gives a small but
stable Edge for white
as you can see
uh dozen beasts thank you I I
um I was not confident enough I I
thought after Queen E4 there's F5
so I calculated this line Queen E6
Bishop E6 F4 Bishop d294 but I stopped
here
and I thought there was like a double
attack but after the simple Bishop G4 E2
square is defended and white has the
bishop pair and in an open board
um
so the centralizing move Queen E4 would
have been best instead we went too
brazenly with Rook D3
oh F5 was best here
yeah after F5 this just puts us to shame
Queen E4 is good but Bishop F4 was
actually best
yeah Queen B3 Rook H3 G6 Bishop G5
and white is better
or at least at least it's double edged
so instead we went here
and of course this is a mistake and
that's kind of oh it's minus three
oh this was a big mistake
and of course as I had told you guys
Bishop D4 and 94
Rook cd1e5 Queen B7 was objectively best
with an equal position
so why is this losing
oh and yeah this is indeed winning
why is this so losing oh it's because of
Queen C5
oh and after Bishop takes d8 Queen takes
C4
oh my lands and there's a threat of
Bishop takes F2 check winning the White
Queen so white ends up also losing the
bishop on d8 okay that is crazy Queen C5
Bishop takes the eight Queen takes E4
and then black gets two pieces for a
rook and a pawn and a monster Bishop on
D4 so what is losing
and
okay white has to play B3 here it's not
totally over
but here black can snag another Pawn
it's still pretty complicated here
though like white still has
a bunch of attacking ideas but
apparently just something like Knight D4
the compensation is obviously
insufficient so
so much uh depth hides beneath the
surface but yeah I'm still happy that I
was able to find this
and then we did everything very cleanly
excellent okay guys hope you enjoyed the
game that was uh that was a lot of fun
we're 2200 Plus
we're going to end the speeder on around
2300.
so we're nearing the end
but there will be a lot more content to
be made afterwards
so thank you all thanks everybody thanks
for hanging out and
I will see everybody later
[Music]